all right Dave is with us in Stockton
California hi Dave how are you well good
afternoon Dave how you doing today
better than I deserve what's up well
that that's good
say I'm with my wife and I are FPU
coordinators and we're debt-free
debt-free and we need your wisdom and
guidance on something where we also have
a little disagreement last year soon
after our son got married we loaded some
money to help him out
really knowing that yeah knowing that we
would never probably see the money again
okay why would you do that your
financial University choir oh you know
what that's a good question that's a
good question I maybe it's because I
haven't product for about a year and I
lost touch with every with that aspect
of it but we volunteered to pay for the
materials that they take a class which
they did but in the end they didn't
discipline us a lot to follow you know
the principles and Ori
building and Bertie's fund at all well
after six months we decided since II
what I'm trying to make this back
anything we kind of let them know we
weren't alone any more money because
they had made no effort to to reimburse
anything of it and and there was no
communication from them and we can't me
over penis - well you know as life goes
several months later the only vehicle
broke down and and it could not be
repaired and my son had no way to get to
work this is where it gets sticky but
knowing that my wife as executor of her
parents trust would be dispersing funds
to all the beneficiaries including him
we both agreed to front about 90% of
what they were received with
understanding they would immediately pay
us back when the checks are written so
the logic was that they were born from
us funds they were already committed to
them by her parents trust as of today we
have not distributed about money but
it's getting a little stick here here
it's going to be disturbing the next
couple of weeks and we wonder what you
do in the meantime they've they took out
a five eight thousand dollar loan to pay
off four months of overdue rent
the otherwise they'd be evicted in our
daughter life just does not want to work
to help out so my angle is there Simmons
mirrors and because they have not
demonstrated to responsibility paint
back to our loan I have strongly
suggested and I think that's about as
far as I can go this is my wife's side
that my wife write the check to them
have them come over inside it over just
and we would write them a check for the
balance of what they didn't borrow from
us nobody we didn't we didn't front them
and it seems simple and we know that if
we approach it that way that would be
successful and it would eliminate the
temptations and using the funds
unnecessarily not cleanest backers
agreed and be in my opinion be more
proactive to solve a $9,000 right yeah
energy right now what's your network now
with that what's your net worth I don't
know 500 600
what's your household income maybe
here's my opinion this is all your fault
my fault yeah okay you loan people money
that were broke and don't handle money
well and you went against everything
that you were supposed to have been
taught by us which was you longer family
money right you're the one made this
mess okay I think now I'm 22 corrected
they're not making it worse
yeah and so well one thing you could do
is just say forget it I don't pay me
back forget it I'm an idiot I shouldn't
given you money I'm never giving you any
more ever under any circumstances right
right she believes that that we should
just be trusting male 2 check to them
and then hope they'll reimburse us even
though sorry embarrass you why that's my
they're not going to that's a completely
ridiculous assumption that is not gonna
happen you mail that check of them
you're never gonna see this money and
then you're gonna have to decide if
you're gonna speak to your own shoulder
and over money or not this is the crap
you get into when you loan family
members and money it's all your fault
so I mean if you want to what if she
wants to walk you through that that's
fine but don't ever do this again
it's just absolutely ludicrous you're
asking for all the trouble you've caused
you caused every bit of this